ARIZONA.
ANDRE TO. MARINO OVER TO  GLOVE
ON THE NET.
CROSBY TRIES TO WRAP IT AROUND
ON CKPEDALING.
COYOTES GO
BRUISES, JUST A COLD AND YOU DO
NOT FEEL LIKE GOING.
YOU ARE LESS THAN 100% HOW REGR
KAPANEN WITH SPEED
SCHMALTZ PUCK ,  YOU SEE THE QU
RELEASE AND JARRY CANNOT GET
OVER  RUST.
LETANG TO MALKIN AND BLIND PASS
STATE AND ONTO
KELLER FOR HAS TO MO
HIGH SLOT.
HE SCORES.
POWER-PLAY GOAL FROM THE PUCK G
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF CHANGES
IN ARIZONA. UINS  ARE ON THE PO-
PLAY OF SPACE. . HE FOUND THE
MIDDLE SPOT BETWEEGOALS, COYOTE
SCORED ON SIX ATTEMPTS.
ONE OF HIS NINTH.
>> Steve: BLUEGER IS OUT SIX
TO EIGHT WEEKS WITH PUTS THE PU
BETWEEN THFOR McGINN.
BACKHANDER, OF McGINN.
THAT IS TOUGH ON
TWO, THEY ERROR.
HE SHOULD HAVE BAILED OUT.
LADD THE SHOT, HE
AND
HOW QUICKLY ARE THE PENGUINS
MOVING THE  TERMS OF PK ICE FOR
>> Steve: BETWEEN THE LEGS ,
THAT IS WHERE THE PUCK WAS